[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want and today we have mindy with us
that was so
that was so smooth it's like you've done
that before oh my gosh you know honestly
that's the smoothest i've ever
done that because i've always not
remembered how to say it because i have
a thing with like memorizing things i
can't ever get it out
yeah no way and or i always choke on my
own words so
that was actually the best i've ever
done great baby thank you very much
it is hard it's just hard sometimes
right sponsored by junebe yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] straw
okay you want to share mine
[Laughter]
all my friends here we know mindy
through the fitness industry yes
and i think she's super cool i know her
uh notorious
i know her through her notorious
bastards
notorious bastard i don't even know her
i just seen her brand before
oh so you're
the brain behind this so i thought
because you could like maybe share
maybe you have respect you throw the r
how you started notorious bastards and
all that
yeah so notorious bastard started off as
like an online
um sticker store on etsy and so
literally i would just sit in my living
room and just draw like stickers on my
ipad and sell them eventually just got
to a point where like i was like up all
night fulfilling orders and i was like
all right [ __ ] this i need to
figure out like a more sustainable
method of doing this and then i just got
off of stickers completely moved into
apparel
and that's what i was doing i was also
doing this while i was working full time
as a
biomedical engineer so like i was just
like super busy but now you go to school
for that what is a biomedical engineer
yeah so sounds dope sounds smart it
smells
like [ __ ]
coming from you it's even funnier it
sounds a lot funny or it sounds a lot
more
um complicated than it actually is and i
think i like those
and yeah more complicated than
biomechanical engineering
it sounds complicated is it
biomechanical or is it biological
engineering biomedical bile is it is
there any engineering
engineering so biomedical there is
engineering right
yeah but without the medical yes okay
i wasn't tripping so what is biomedical
engineering
yeah so it's like a newer sector of
engineering i think it's relatively new
but yeah so we don't know about it we're
not stupid exactly we're not stupid
i am it's kind of like engineering
applied to medical equipment equipment
but you also
have to know how like the human anatomy
works so it's like one thing to say
hey i can fix a blood pressure machine
but
at the same time when you're diagnosing
an issue or troubleshooting an issue
how do you know it's the machine how do
you know it's not the patient so you
have to kind of
know yeah a lot of times
stupid ass it's like the machine's not
wrong you are dumb ass
or the user could be wrong a lot of
times it's the users the nurses
like nurses i have nothing against
nurses but they're not like the most
tech savvy people i would say
and so a lot of times so i'll give you
like a textbook example of like a call
that i would get right
nurse calls they're like hey my blood
pressure machine isn't working and i'd
be like what's wrong
and they would say something like oh the
blood pressure cuff it just keeps
inflating and it keeps inflating and we
don't know why it's not getting full
because they're not trained in that
they're trained to uh figure out like if
the medicine and all that double check
and all the other stuff right
yeah they're just trained based off the
reading that this blood pressure machine
gives them so like they can't even start
their job
until they have this rating and so for
me i had to come in and assess the
situation and figure out what's going on
and you you go in and plug it in and
you're like ah fixed
turn it on and turn it off a lot of
calls no
on and i'm like okay is it on did you
press the power maybe you're not going
to believe this but
fashion don't work anymore sometimes it
would be that bad
like they would call me and just start
mumbling this gibberish and i'm like huh
like what are you talking about one time
i answered a call where they were like
oh like
you have to come right now we're in the
or this machine won't turn on
and i was like did you plug it in can
you trace the power cord and like
put your eyeballs on it and make sure
it's in the outlet they're like yes we
did that and i was like oh [ __ ] this is
happening
so like i run over there i get all
scrubbed up i go into this room
and i trace this machine's power cord
and it's plugged into
its own power strip no no the machine's
plugged into a power strip and the power
strip
is plugged into a power strip wow and i
was like that's not how electricity
that's like works harry potter [ __ ] like
that's like there's no way it's not like
harry potter just wave your water just
wanted to did you humiliate them or did
you go like oh yeah it's been fixed
i tried not to be rude but i walked over
there and i was like yeah i'm just gonna
unplug the power strip from the power
strip and put it into the wall
and the moment i did that like all the
alarms like
like okay we're on yeah so that's kind
of and these are the people that are
operating on people
in in surgery and stuff it's because
they're trained and human yeah there's
other things you
something got not trained in plugging
equipment there's this hierarchy right
so like the surgeons are not the people
that are responsible for setting up the
equipment usually it's like a tech
and that person might be so used to
doing the same routine thing in and out
that when they get like a new piece of
equipment
you would think that okay so it's like a
new device figure it out plug it into
the wall
but they're moving so fast they have so
many things going on they're prepping
people dying
you know when people are dying people
panic
yeah that tends to happen a lot mm-hmm
you know you worked in the hospital
right
yeah i didn't work with patients but
yeah yeah yeah so
biomedical engineering did you have to
go to school for that or what
what is but it sounds like equipment
like the iris
the yeah the pumps yeah yeah that's a
[ __ ] hundred of them those
that was my job i used to i worked in
the spd okay
she wasn't the idiot that called you no
i'd be the she's the one that's
though i don't like that sometimes yeah
like with the steroids not the
sterilizer like the i forgot all these
equipments i haven't worked in it for
like five six years i think
damn the tons of lighters
i'm usually the guy that goes to the er
okay
you've been to the er oh many times in
my childhood
they didn't think i was gonna survive
past 20 dude
yeah what's the craziest thing you went
into the year i had all kinds of
damages man i had pneumonia as a kid
i had this crap that wouldn't leave my
system for like a week straight
like literally yeah i had to get like a
cocka scan like you know when when the
ultra ultra
ultra boost game scanned the ultra scan
right like the shoes yeah that's what
they call them right the ultra
yeah oh yeah that one so instead of
putting it in the vagina they put it in
your butt
wait did you put it in i don't i don't
know what
vaginal ultrasounds or like on top
ultrasound i don't know if i got an
ultrasound because i just remember
um they just put some cream on my belly
and then they had this thing yeah that's
an ultrasound
but why would it go inside your [ __ ]
no
that's a that's an anal camera right
it's like a girl joke
basically because well how would i know
a girl joking no that's like she's
laughing
i'm trying to explain it to you that
there are vaginal ultra is this funny
i want to know more about anal cameras
i still don't get it i'm sorry but i had
a i had a i had a piece of crap that
wouldn't leave my intestines
and then it was some of the most
excruciating pain ever
um yeah constipated is that considered
constipated yeah it was like crazy
constipation and then like i would sit
on the toilet forever and nothing will
come out
yeah it was crazy literally yeah the
doctor said i had any
intestinal blockage yeah i think i just
only ate like
meat at one point like i was i was just
like give me a steak remember that
and then the doctor gave me some booty
pills and i was like
i can't do it doctor and then um
he tried to put one in and i was like it
just shot right back out like a bullet
and i'm like i can't do it it is yeah
it's awesome yeah and i was like i'm
sorry doc can't do this they made you
swallow the boot the pills in your booty
it's going in somewhere
yeah i remember going to the er i never
broke a bomb though but like i
always had to get stitches because i
fell in bushes
and things like that yeah and bushes
yeah or like i fell off my bike or
whatever
like um i remember my friend was chasing
me on the
wall like you know those cinder block
walls or whatever
uh uh i don't know we had him in my
neighborhood and then the kids would run
on top of them
and then he was chasing me and then i
was running back and forth
and i was like [ __ ] it and i jumped in
this bush and i
[ __ ] got in and i got out with all
this blood coming out
oh my gosh you know you strike me as a
person that might have gotten injured
through
uh sex acts as well
no i'm i'm gentle in bed are you but
speaking of sex
shout outs to adam and eve for
sponsoring this video
because the best part of staying home
these days is also
playing at home and they have toys
for all kinds of people him her whether
you're in a straight relationship
homosexual relationship whatever
you want to put things in your butt on
their dick for girls they have
everything and they even have a
masturbator section so you've been
jacking off to your hand this whole time
oh looking at it i might get a fake butt
yeah
they have full love dolls yeah i think i
would i think a lot of those toys look
very
fun but you know what you could take
advantage of the downtime and choose
almost any one item at 50
off so you'll also get 10 free
boredom busting gifts including six
spicy movies
a three-piece bonus kit and best of all
free shipping delivered discreetly
right to your door because you don't
want a whole box that says porno
or a sex toy yeah you don't wanna when a
box comes and it says
dildo you don't want that right
because grandma could have picked it up
and she's like oh it's my dildo he goes
nope nope no that's yours joe
so uh that's kind of embarrassing so uh
just remember to use the code otr
that's otr check it out baby get 50 off
one item at adamandeve.com there we go
and use the code
offer otr would you guys ever buy
a sex toy in person in person like going
up to like
wait do they even have stores anymore
with sex toys in there do you
walk into one i feel like that's not a
weird thing to do
yeah have you bought a sex time person
maybe if you're like a weenie it is but
yep
i don't know what are you doing i'm a
weenie man i totally would yeah have you
though
no i've never it depends well i totally
will like i don't think it's like
something to be embarrassed about
or like i don't think like you walking
in there and buying a toy makes you like
a like a sexual deviant or anything like
i feel like there's a big stigma around
it
but there's like i guess like not
necessarily weenie but maybe like more
traditional
sense because traditional like
weenies easy to say if you're at a sex
store right
the person that's [ __ ] buying like
selling this [ __ ] is they're trying to
make money they're not like
you're buying this [ __ ] i think it's
more when you're walking out walking and
walking out
but the can you imagine the cashier
judging every single person that buys a
dildo at a porn shop i'm pretty sure
maybe they're just attacking the porn
shop no i think they're
more worried about the other people in
the plaza like when you come out of the
sex store what do the people in the
laundromat think of you
yeah well that's why like if you just
order online like
adam and eve you don't have to worry
about that stuff that whole stigma
but don't you also want to be proud that
you embrace your sexuality so you come
out of there and you go yeah you
laundromat [ __ ] you're a
weenie yeah i know girls that are like
stoked to share like like i have this
one friend i won't say her name
but like she bought this like she bought
this dildo that had like
little bunny ears on it i had that one
it's called jack rabbit
okay yeah the jackrabbit and she's
stoked i remember going to her house one
time this is when we were like in
college and like
young and stupid but she like told me
all about it and she's like yeah i have
a date with el tonight and i was like
who's l
like she normally tells me about all her
guys and i'm like who's l
and she's like oh i'll show you and she
goes and grabs out this pink sparkly
rabbit dildo thing and i was like what
was she like you want to borrow it
it's [ __ ] dope
i actually didn't like it that much it
seems it seems pretty extra
yeah is it just me or do i think it's
weirder
i think it's more okay for girls to
share sex toys but i think if guys were
to share pocket [ __ ] wait no no no
one's sharing it
yeah no but you're saying that if you
had to choose between the two
it's not as gross if girls share it yeah
like share about them right like me
telling yourself
he's talking about oh no don't do that
do not do that no one's doing that no
one's doing that at all these days
no i don't think i don't recommend them
never i don't think ever
oh i think it's because we see it in the
pornos so it's normal oh they're always
sharing toys in the porno
but in pornos they stick it in someone's
butthole and then the person that stuck
it in their butthole pulls it out and
then puts it in their own mouth so
cause they're cleaning it and then
they're quite so that doesn't happen in
real life
no okay so i'm not having sex with mindy
why would i use mindy's well she's not
hot enough to you
no i think it's because we we watch porn
with like lesbians and they're sharing
sex toys so it's like
oh yeah girls probably do that all the
time but let's first establish that
porn in itself thank you heightened
version of what
people think they're also not real
lesbians i know
it's just okay never mind but i was i
was talking
i was talking about from a realistic
standpoint where like sometimes i don't
have a toothbrush
right and i borrow her toothbrush he
does so people
so people should say they worship people
i don't want to share it so i can see
two chicks at like a dorm room
and they're like oh [ __ ] i need a jack
off i don't have a toy can i borrow
yours i heard you moaning like crazy in
the other room and you're having all
this kind of fun
i need to release some stress so her
borrowing it but i can't
i it just feels weirder when the guy
it's like if i hear joe moaning in
another hey can i borrow your pocket
[ __ ] i'm a bust in it too honestly it's
not as gross
imagining girls to do it but i feel like
guys are more gross
but they're more likely to share and
also i feel like
like just like sticking your dick into
something and sharing that something
versus
sticking something into you and sharing
that thing with someone that's going
into
her too is like completely different you
think the guy is worse
you think the guy was worse i think the
girl one
is worse because he's going inside my
body well i think the girl tools are
easier to clean
true that is a good point because
imagine getting a pocket [ __ ] full of
[ __ ] yeah
and you're just like all right bro i'm
desperate
but if you get a dildo it's all well
it's just dry and it's kind of like ah
well
i guess i can rinse it off but on the
flip side it's easy to clean a dildo how
easy is it
for you to clean germs out of your
vagina yeah
exactly is that hard to do cleaning the
cleaning
of flesh i i threw away my fleshlight
because i was like dude
this [ __ ] takes [ __ ] forever it's a
process man
like inside out i mean you look like a
sock
how about the dishwasher it's like you
gotta go through the whole
process of hot water wait is that
dishwasher safe though
because what if it melts oh yeah it's
like a deformed did you have it
didn't have a challenge for next time
it's okay it's a game yeah it's just a
new
masturbation should always be a
challenge yeah i don't know
i don't know it's a lot of work you know
what i find really odd
are the people that are heavily against
masturbation
like who's against masturbation usually
i thought christians were cool with it
because they're like
i'd rather have you masturbate than to
have sex no like i think there's some
like christians or other religions that
are heavily against it or
because recently i saw something on
social media about like mothers against
masturbation
or something like a facebook group and
i'm like
why like why do you because she wants
her son or daughter to be babies let's
consider masturbation
if you're a guy in her jacking off but
you don't bust is that masturbation
i think as soon as you touch yourself
yes and it's more than three strokes
yeah well and it's pleasurable and it's
on your genitals then i think that's
fine what if you got a mosquito bite and
you're scratching it and it's
pleasurable
yeah what if you a mosquito bit your
dick yeah and you got to keep jacking it
off
to do this on your i'm itching it or you
could just go like this
i wouldn't say that's masturbation i'd
say that you have a bad itch
so what if you scratch it but for some
reason then you come
then that's nice but you don't even know
you have to [ __ ] itch it because it's
so itchy
painful and then you [ __ ]
yeah i mean i didn't masturbate i had to
collateral masturbation so there are
contacts there's mothers there's a whole
group called mothers against
masturbation
apparently are they hypocrites
or are they trying to control their kids
masturbating they're just trying to
control it so they'll jack off all day
for sure then it's inevitable that's not
fair
to think about um oh yeah i watch this
youtube video
about like an ex cult member that like
escaped and just like was talking about
their
experience in this cult and in the cult
that they were in i don't remember what
it was called
but in the call that they were in they
were told never to
masturbate but it's it's interesting to
me that they didn't call it masturbation
they called it self-rape
self so they rebranded it they renamed
it to make it sound like
it was something that that was terrible
yeah
i don't want to rape myself the genitals
didn't consent yeah the genitals didn't
give consent though
oh that would that have been genius if
the cult leader is like wait
did you just rape yourself and they're
like no no i i had a conversation with
myself and
it's [ __ ] good we're good that's a
weird conversation too about consent
like
like there are people that okay so like
there are people that say
human breast milk is technically vegan
because
the moms are consenting to the
conception of is that how they determine
if it's vegan
yeah it's like if it's something that is
produced by an
animal like they don't have to they
don't have the ability to give you
consent
so like chickens lay eggs they don't
have the ability to give you consent to
like eat their eggs so eggs aren't vegan
i think that's you they lay egg in there
they lay the egg and they're like
this is a veganism wait isn't it
is it yeast or bacteria they don't eat
that either was that is that a vegan
thing
i don't know that's a good point living
in it yeah this is alive right when it's
yeah but they can't give you consent
yeah than that then you count some
vegans don't eat figs because
figs are like a big part of um like a
like a wasp's ability to reproduce do
you know that
that's probably why i got attacked by a
wasp the other day man [ __ ] that guy i
was picking on my fig tree that was my
fake tree not his
he claimed it before you though you know
what i did the other day
all right last year i didn't even get to
eat one big
and i had like hundreds of them right
sucks but some crow or squirrels came
and [ __ ] it all up
those are two very different things
that's what i never seen the culprit i
don't know it's who it was right
except him so i'm imagining
it's okay to imagine what animal got
them i gave options
that's just what happened okay so it
could have been a possum i don't know
but here's the thing i was recommended
to doing
um these nets that you can tie to each
fruit right so i got like a hundred bags
tied them all up and i was like this
time you ain't getting that [ __ ]
the other day i went to my backyard
there's a bunch of those
nets all over the [ __ ] floor holes in
them man i just sat down like picking up
all of them i was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude
so now i don't know what to do oh what
don't they put like those metal sheets
around the tree
trunk or the bark of it so that if it is
a rodent then it can't
climb it okay it's too slippery yeah
well what if it's a crow
how big is this tree i don't have all
your solutions okay
or imagine our round table and imagine
um to this to the roof right here that's
a big [ __ ] fig tree that's a big tree
yeah it's a big dream but you know why i
get pissed is because they're bougie
like they'll go
for the most ripest fruits and then
they'll raid it and then they'll wait
until the other ones get ripe
so i never get a chance to eat a fig
dude
like they get it right before it gets
ripe but now you learned
it's important for wasps
i